Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速告知大家一个正在进行的令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造能为你带来源源不断收入的管道，而不是不断地用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“冲刺经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家的人、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up on today's episode, we are thinking about masters, distance learning masters, part-time to be specific. There's so much to gain and I am joined by a student who
这些原则同样适用于你。此外，还有由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特恩特（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士一对一辅导一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好啦，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我们将探讨硕士学位，具体来说是远程学习硕士和非全日制硕士。这里面有很多收获，而且我也邀请了一位
is completing his qualification as well. Hope you will find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Really lovely to have you here. Thank you to those of you who are regular listeners and a big welcome to you if you are a brand new listener or watcher. If you are watching this on YouTube, please do take a moment to subscribe to the channel, like some content and fling around some lovely comments too. That would be marvellous. If you are listening as an MP3, please do consider liking, rating and reviewing on Spotify and Apple. That would be so appreciated. So when I was an aspiring
正在攻读学历的学生作客。希望你会觉得非常有用。嗨，欢迎收听“有志心理学家播客”（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。我是玛丽安·特恩特博士，是一名合格的临床心理学家。很高兴你能来到这里。谢谢你们这些老听友，如果新来的听友或观众，也热烈欢迎你们。如果你正在 YouTube 上观看，请花一点时间订阅频道，给内容点赞，并留下一些精彩的评论。那就太棒了。如果你是通过 MP3 收听，请考虑在 Spotify 和 Apple 上点赞、评分和评论。我们将不胜感激。所以，当我还是一个立志成为心理学家的人时，
psychologist, I took the decision to do a master's. And at the time, it was quite radical to do it kind of mainly distance learning. And I know that is more common. People often ask me, well, should I do a master's? What sort of master's should I do? And so today we're looking at that. And I hope you'll find the episode really interesting and it might give you some ideas and some options to how to pick the right sort of masters to blend around your life so that you can thrive, not just survive as an aspiring psychologist or mental health professional. Hope you find it useful and I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side. So Gavin, it's lovely to have you here. Thank you for reaching out to me. I know that
我决定攻读硕士学位。在当时，选择主要是远程学习的形式是相当激进的。我知道现在这更常见了。人们经常问我：“嗯，我应该读硕士吗？我该读什么样的硕士？”所以今天我们就在探讨这个问题。我希望你会觉得这集节目非常有趣，它可能会给你一些启发和选择，教你如何选择适合你生活的硕士类型，让你在作为有志心理学家或心理健康专业人士时不仅能生存，还能蓬勃发展。希望你觉得有用，我也期待在节目后半部分与你交流。那么加文（Gavin），很高兴你能来到这里。谢谢你主动联系我。我知道
you heard me talk on the British Psychological Society keynote. So that's how I think I came to your attention. Thank you for reaching out. Thank you for joining me. It was my pleasure. I listened to you on that keynote and you just came across really engaging, really kind of inspiring. That always piques my interest. I like people that come across in that way. So I started checking you out and, yeah, as you say, I reached out and here we are. Here we are indeed.
你听过我在英国心理学会（British Psychological Society）主旨演讲上的发言。我想我就是这样进入你的视线的。谢谢你主动联系我，谢谢你加入我的节目。这是我的荣幸。我在那个主旨演讲上听了你的发言，你给人的感觉非常引人入胜，也非常鼓舞人心。这总是能激起我的兴趣。我喜欢以这种方式给人留下深刻印象的人。所以我开始关注你，然后，正如你所说，我联系了你，我们就这样见面了。确实如此。
And I was intrigued by you because I don't think we have chatted to super loads of men on this podcast. So it's always nice to get a masculine narrative. But also you shared with me a number of kind of difficult factors that make your journey in psychology that bit trickier. Before we go through some of those could you tell us what your current state of play is in terms of career and where you might want to get to? Yeah so I currently work for a large organization it's my kind of day job I'm a compliance manager which is effectively looking at what the kind of frontline people do, what people do with customers, and whether that's being done in the right way and whether we're getting the right sort of outcomes for customers. I have a few kind of speciality areas within that in that I can look at a specific population of customers in particular, which is the customers that are defined. I don't really like this definition, but vulnerable customers, which is a kind of regulatory definition, which basically means customers that need a bit more help.
我对你很感兴趣，因为我觉得我们在这个播客里没有和超多的男性聊过。所以能听到男性的叙述总是很好的。但你也和我分享了许多困难因素，这些因素让你的心理学之路变得更加棘手。在我们探讨其中一些因素之前，你能告诉我们你目前在职业生涯方面的现状是什么，以及你想达到什么目标吗？好的，我目前在一家大型机构工作，这是我的全职工作。我是一名合规经理，实际上就是监督一线员工的工作、他们如何对待客户，以及这些是否以正确的方式进行，我们是否为客户取得了正确的成果。我在其中有一些专业领域，我可以特别关注特定群体的客户，即被定义为——我其实不太喜欢这个定义——脆弱客户的群体。这是一个监管定义，基本上意味着需要更多帮助的客户。
So I'm quite passionate in that area anyway. Kind of links into my own experiences as well. And I also do a couple of podcasts now, actually. So I will plug them. One is the Safe Place podcast, which is my main one. And then another one was a brand new one that we're just starting out, which is called Disabling Me, which is a kind of ironic take on life as a person with disabilities.
所以我对这个领域本身就相当有热情。这也与我自己的经历有关。而且，其实我现在还做几个播客。所以我要宣传一下。一个是“安全港播客”（Safe Place podcast），这是我的主要播客；另一个是我们刚刚开始的一个全新播客，叫做“致残的我”（Disabling Me），这是对残疾人生活的一种讽刺性看法。
Also gives you a little bit of flavour of what I might have experienced as well, which I know we'll touch on. Great. And you're also. And obviously my kind of career trajectory is now thinking about what i want to do next and what i want to do for the rest of my career so i'm slightly older in age which you might be able to tell by some of the gray hair um so i i'm kind of nearing 40 i've had a couple of career changes uh in my my career to date one that i should have made a lot earlier was was this move to towards psychology um it feels the most appropriate for me um in in multiple ways but particularly it feels most
这也让你对我的经历有了一点了解，我知道我们等一下会触及这一点。太棒了。而且你还在……显然，我的职业轨迹现在正在思考我下一步想做什么，以及我想在余下的职业生涯中做什么。所以我年纪稍微大一点，你也许能从我的一些白发中看出这一点……嗯，我快四十岁了。在迄今为止的职业生涯中，我有过几次职业转型。其中一个我应该早点做出的改变，就是转向心理学……在多方面，这对我来说似乎都是最合适的，
appropriate for the kind of good natured element of of kind of who I I feel I am and and who I want to be as well so that's kind of what drives me to to move forward with that too. Great thank you and you're studying for an MSc in psychology at the moment as well is that right? I am yeah so I've actually got an essay in in a couple of weeks time so it's very stressful at the moment as I'm sure many will remember in my second year I'm doing it part-time online through the University of Derby so yeah lots going on and then just thrown into the mix we've had our second child recently who is about eight weeks old currently so yeah lots lots going on lots of lots of exciting things. Well congratulations and I hope um your second child is thriving and fitting into family life um as well as can be expected um and how many years is your part-time
特别是它最符合我内心那种善良的本质，以及我想成为什么样的人。所以这就是推动我继续前进的动力。太棒了，谢谢。而且你目前也在攻读心理学理学硕士（MSc），对吗？是的，没错。实际上我几周后就要交一篇论文了，所以现在压力非常大，我相信很多人都还记得。我目前通过德比大学（University of Derby）在线攻读兼读学位，现在是第二年。所以，是的，有很多事情在忙。最近刚刚加入我们生活中的第二个孩子，目前大约八周大，所以有很多事情在忙，有很多令人兴奋的事情。
msc you expecting to finish at the end of this year so the end of next year uh that i should finish it so this year is the kind of end of the bulk of teaching modules and then I'll have a year doing the research elements of it interested to kind of see how that's going to work and then obviously it's on to then applying for Declan is what I'm looking at applying for so okay we'll have all that to look forward to. Can I ask a slightly nosy question because I know that our audience might be wondering as well in terms of tuition fees for part-time masters do they literally just sort of take the nine thousand split it across three years or does it not work quite like that? So it depends as with all these things so you can either pay it up front and you get a bit of a discount if you do if. Most people aren't in that position.
祝贺你，我希望你的第二个孩子茁壮成长，并且像预期的那样很好地融入家庭生活。你的兼读制硕士需要读几年？你预计什么时候完成？我预计在今年年底到明年年底完成。所以今年是大部分教学模块的尾声，然后我将有一年时间来做研究部分。我很想看看那会如何进行，当然，接下来我要考虑申请邓肯（Declan）项目，这就是我正在考虑申请的……所以，好吧，我们有很多事情可以期待。我能问一个有点八卦的问题吗？因为我知道我们的听众可能也在想，关于兼读制硕士的学费，他们是字面意义上把九千英镑分摊到三年里，还是运作方式不完全是这样的？
I would say that's mainly either if you're just very fortunate in that you've got a spare 10 grand sitting around. Let's be honest, that's pretty rare these days. Or potentially getting sponsored by your employer, they might pay for it. But again, unless you're already of already in that broader field, probably not going to happen. Or then there's the kind of population that I'm in where I'm self-funding. I actually use a kind of mixture of earnings
这得看情况，所有这些事情都是这样。你可以选择一次性付清，如果这样的话你会得到一点折扣。大多数人并不处于那种财务状况。我会说，这种情况通常要么发生在你非常幸运，手头刚好有一万英镑闲钱的时候。老实说，如今这相当罕见。或者可能会得到雇主的赞助，他们可能会为你支付学费。但同样，除非你已经在这个更广阔的领域工作，否则这大概不会发生。然后就是像我这样自费的群体。我实际上结合了
because I'm in a fortunate position in that way, mixed with a bit of support from the student loan company. And it's paid out. I pay it monthly, actually. So I pay a kind of split across the, what will be three years. And you just pay 200 and something pounds a month that I pay.
自己的收入，因为我很幸运能处于那种状况，再加上学生贷款公司的一点支持。它是分期支付的。实际上我是按月支付的。所以我把学费分摊在这将是三年的时间里。我每月支付二百多英镑。
And then the kind of student loan comes in quarters. But there's lots of different ways of paying it. I find personally the most easy for me to budget and the most easy for me to kind of keep going with and and just know what's what what's kind of going out um is that that monthly that monthly bit partly because if it's three monthly I'm liable to forget and then suddenly have this big bill to go out so I choose to do it monthly. Thank you so much for that context and it sounds like you're actually able to be quite flexible in terms of what works
然后学生贷款是按季度发放的。但有很多不同的支付方式。我个人觉得，最容易让我做预算、最容易让我坚持下去、最清楚到底有什么支出的是这种按月支付的方式。部分原因在于，如果是按季度支付，我很有可能会忘记，然后突然就会收到一大笔账单要付，所以我选择按月支付。非常感谢你提供这些背景信息，听起来你确实能够非常灵活地安排适合自己的方式，
for you so you get a salary so actually monthly usually works better for you. Exactly yeah and I think that's that it's an important thing to to kind of make sure people really understand because any form of of kind of postgraduate study often seems really unaccessible but there are lots of ways now so yeah it's actually better than my um my first kind of postgraduate study so i studied law uh gosh about 10 years ago makes me feel very old um but yeah i studied law about 10 years ago and that was postgraduate study all self-funded and there wasn't really the kind of student loan support back then in the way that there is now so it's not ideal it's never ideal to self-fund but there are many more options now to um to kind of get through different different forms of study postgraduate and in my view it's it's
所以你有薪水，实际上按月支付通常对你更合适。完全正确。我认为这是一个很重要的、需要让人们真正理解的事情，因为任何形式的研究生学习通常都让人觉得遥不可及，但现在有很多途径了。所以，实际上这比我第一次攻读研究生还要好。我大约在10年前学过法律——天哪，这让我觉得自己非常老——但是的，我大约10年前学过法律，那是全自费的研究生学习，当时并没有现在这种学生贷款支持。这并不理想，自费绝不是理想的选择，但现在有很多更多的选择来度过不同形式的研究生学习。在我看来，
worthwhile doing thank you so i would be imagining that you're doing what's called a conversion masters which needs to be accredited by the british psychological society is that right gavin it is yeah yeah could you tell us a bit about that? So if someone's like, I don't know any of the words that Marianne just said, could you tell us what that is and why that's important? Psychological society, obviously, is the kind of body that sits around psychologists to make sure that people are doing the right jobs in the right way with the right qualifications. There's lots of other stuff that they do as well. But, you know, let's focus on that element.
这是非常值得去做的。谢谢。我想你读的是所谓的转换硕士（conversion masters），这需要获得英国心理学会（BPS）的认证，是这样吗，加文？是的，确实如此。你能跟我们多讲讲这个吗？如果有人心想：“玛丽安刚才说的这些词我一个都不懂”，你能告诉我们那是什么以及为什么它很重要吗？心理学会显然是围绕心理学家的一个机构，旨在确保人们以正确的方式、凭借正确的资格胜任正确的工作。他们还做很多其他的事情。但我们先关注这一方面。
And to make your way through the the process to become a psychologist in whichever way that you're that you're kind of going to do it you need to get through accredited courses so the bps um accredit certain courses that meet certain criteria um in universities uh university of derby where i am is one of those that's online accredited. There's not that many that are online accredited. So it is a bit of a kind of slim pickings out there. But fortunately, Derby's very good anyway for psychology. So I'm kind of fortunate in that. And then you can also do it obviously face-to-face depending on your personal situation.
要在成为心理学家的道路上不断前行，无论你选择哪种方式，你都需要通过获得认证的课程。BPS 会认证符合大学某些特定标准的特定课程。我所在的德比大学就是提供在线认证的大学之一。提供在线认证的学校并不多，所以选择其实有点捉襟见肘。但幸运的是，德比大学在心理学方面本来就很不错，所以我很幸运。然后你显然也可以根据个人情况选择面对面授课。
That then allows you, once you've completed that, to get what's called graduate basis within the BPS, which then allows you to go on to your kind of next stage of applying for whichever route you choose to apply for. So it could be another master's, it could be a health psychology master's as an example. You could be looking at educational psychology, clinical psychology being the one that I think most people are probably aware of and looking at. But you need to go through that process. Otherwise, you'd have gone through it doing your undergraduate degree, which again would need to be a BPS kind of accredited course and it gives you a similar sort of status through and that gets you to that graduate it's just that it's at a master's level because I've already studied in my case I've already studied a couple of different degrees and stuff in the past so yeah it's just a slightly different route into getting ultimately to the same position as doing an undergrad. Great thank you so much for clarifying that for our listeners because um i know that as
一旦你完成学业，这就能让你获得 BPS 的所谓“毕业生基础资格”（graduate basis），然后你就可以进入下一阶段，申请你选择的任何路径。可以是另一个硕士学位，比如健康心理学硕士。你可以考虑教育心理学，临床心理学可能是大多数人最了解和关注的方向。但你必须经历这个过程。否则，你就得在本科阶段完成，而本科也需要是 BPS 认证的课程，这会让你获得类似的状态，从而达到毕业生基础资格。只不过这是硕士级别的，因为我已经学习过——就我而言，我过去已经学过几个不同的学位等——所以，是的，这只是通往最终与本科相同终点的一条略有不同的路径。太棒了，非常感谢你为我们的听众澄清这一点，因为我知道正如你所说，
you say the accreditation for the undergrad is really important to be able to get that graduate basis but actually the masters there's not you don't have if you if you've already got your graduate basis undergrad you don't technically have to do an accredited bps masters it's kind of it might be nice to have but it's not an essential but if you don't have the undergrad gbr already you do need to do the conversion masters yeah and it's it's similar in a few different professions so law has a similar thing in that you have to go through a conversion course if your undergraduate wasn't in law it's the same thing in psychology it's making sure that everybody has got that base level of skills to go on to the next stage
本科的认证对于获得毕业生基础资格非常重要，但实际上对于硕士来说，如果你在本科阶段就已经获得了毕业生基础资格，从技术上讲，你并不一定要读一个经过 BPS 认证的硕士学位。有这个可能很好，但并非必不可少。不过，如果你还没有获得本科的 GBR 资格，你就确实需要读转换硕士。是的，这在其他几个行业也很类似。法律行业也有类似的情况，如果你的本科专业不是法律，你就必须通过转换课程。心理学也是如此，它确保每个人都具备基础水平的技能，以便进入下一阶段。
and it's in that kind of controlled function of being an accreditation kind of process so it makes a lot of sense it does mean that you've got a lot more academia to go through than some other routes in life. But again, it makes relative sense for that to be the case in psychology. And, you know, law and accountancy even has got a similar sort of thing. So there's lots of lots of different routes that you have to take. Great. And if someone's thinking, oh oh I might quite fancy a part-time distance learning masters I wonder what that involves what does it look like day-to-day week-to-week month-to-month Gavin so I'm quite lucky um and so that was a slight wry smile for
这是一种作为认证流程的受控职能，所以非常合理。这意味着你比生活中其他一些路径需要经历更多的学术学习。但同样，在心理学中，这种情况的存在相对来说也是合情合理的。而且，法律甚至会计也有类似的做法。所以你必须走很多不同的路线。太棒了。如果有人在想：“哦，我可能挺想读一个兼读制远程学习硕士的，”不知道那涉及什么？加文，它的日常生活、每周、每月的状态是怎样的？我很幸运——对于那些没有看视频的人来说，这里有一个略带苦笑的微笑——
those of you that aren't watching um because in many ways I'm kind of not so lucky. But in this context, I'm quite lucky, really, because I have flexibility in my job, which means that I work a condensed week. So I work four days in my kind of day job. Then I have Fridays, which is predominantly focused on me doing my study. Sounds really simple. It's never quite that simple. So you need roughly 20 hours a week to be able to kind of get through the course content, all the other reading, you know, to start thinking about essays and the like.
因为在许多方面我其实没那么幸运。但在这种情况下，我真的很幸运，因为我的工作很灵活，这意味着我实行压缩工作周。我在主业工作四天。然后周五主要用于我的学习。听起来很简单。事情从来没有那么简单。所以你每周大约需要20个小时来完成课程内容、所有其他的阅读，以及开始思考论文等事情。
So that's if you're doing it part time in the same way that I'm doing it. You can also do an accelerated course, which is basically twice the amount. You do two modules, which means that you need 40 hours a week. So if you think about it, that is pretty much working a full time job there or thereabouts for most people just on your study so one of the things that i would always express to everybody is that before you go into any form of additional study whilst you're working even part-time i mean i i remember in my in my kind of law studies i worked part-time in hmv and thought that'll be easy it's gonna be absolutely fine it was an absolute slog um i was working in in in retail stores loving it because it was hmv and i love music and i love film and all that sort of stuff
如果你像我一样以兼读制形式学习，情况就是这样。你也可以选择加速课程，这基本上是双倍的工作量。你要同时修读两个模块，这意味着你需要每周40个小时。所以如果你想想看，对大多数人来说，这几乎就是一份全职工作的时间，完全花在学习上了。因此，我总是会向所有人表达的一点是，在你开始任何形式的额外学习之前，哪怕是一边工作一边兼读——我的意思是，我记得在我的法律学习期间，我在 HMV（英国音像零售商）兼职，当时还以为“这会很简单，绝对没问题”。结果却是一场绝对的苦战。我在零售店工作，我很喜欢它，因为那是 HMV，我喜欢音乐、电影和所有这些东西，
and i was enjoying my legal studies as well because the academic side is really interesting um but it's a lot of work to kind of go through so you really need to think about before you kind of go up go out there and go right i'm going to do a master's first of all think masters is quite an undertaking no matter how you're doing it it's a lot of study it's a lot of thoughts a lot of making sure that you've got a structured environment to work through and that you're able to give your best um kind of best chance of of kind of succeeding well um in that master's and then you just got to think about your time so have you realistically got 20 hours a week that you can not just kind of sit down whilst you're watching tv and and kind of study but actually really sit down and properly study you've got to digest the information you've got to have some way of
我也很喜欢我的法律学习，因为学术方面真的很有趣。但要应付过去确实有很多工作要做。所以你真的需要在开始之前三思，然后心想：“好吧，我要去读个硕士了。”首先，无论你以何种方式学习，硕士都是一项艰巨的任务。它有很多学习内容，有很多思考，有很多确保你拥有结构化的学习环境并能够全力以赴以期成功的事情。然后你必须考虑你的时间：你是否切合实际地拥有每周20小时的时间，不是边看电视边坐在那里学习，而是真正坐下来好好学习？你必须消化信息，你必须找到某种方法
trying to get that memory recall going on um otherwise it's great to read it once but it's probably not going to go in so it's a lot of work um but it's incredibly interesting um i've learned loads about myself in doing it so my my last module was pain psychology it's probably worth just saying at this point so one of the things that that i can live with is a condition called complex regional pain syndrome which is a relatively rare pain syndrome it's kind of known as i mean there's lots of different names for it to put it to context one of those is the suicide disease because there's a high prevalence uh this is kind of a global thing a high prevalence of suicide because it's just so extremely painful
来调动你的记忆复习，否则，读一遍是一回事，但可能根本记不住。所以工作量很大，但极其有趣。我在学习过程中对自我有了很多了解。我的上一个模块是疼痛心理学。此时值得一提的是，我身上带有一种叫做“复杂区域疼痛综合征”（CRPS）的病症，这是一种相对罕见的疼痛综合征。它有很多不同的名字，为了便于理解，其中一个名字叫“自杀病”，因为它的自杀率很高——这是一个全球性的现象——自杀率高是因为它实在太痛了。
there's a really good documentary uh on netflix that is uh taking care of maya that gives you a good kind of context of what it is like to live with the condition a bit more about it but also some of the kind of medical stuff that that goes on so i had the opportunity then to actually study what it was that was going on from a psychological standpoint and a certain amount of kind of medical stuff as well because pain psychology you've got to understand a little bit about it um on the other side designed a website that that that was um that was all about crps and that was the the kind of assessment so slightly different assessment style um i just learned lots about the condition that i live with the nature of pain the sorts of things that i could possibly do to to kind of help myself
Netflix 上有一部非常好的纪录片叫《带走玛雅》（Taking Care of Maya），它能让你更好地了解患有这种病症是什么体验，以及其中涉及的一些医疗情况。这也让我有机会真正从心理学的角度，以及一定程度的医学角度去研究到底发生了什么，因为研究疼痛心理学，你必须对它有所了解。另一方面，我设计了一个关于 CRPS 的网站，这就是当时的评估任务——稍微不同的评估风格。我了解了很多关于我所患疾病的性质、疼痛的本质，以及我为了自我帮助和应对可以做的事情。
and and kind of help work through. And just pure coincidence, I was also going through a pain management clinic, which is basically where you've got a health psychologist, physiotherapist, sort of a kind of anesthesiologist in the background, and then usually a kind of pain specialist nurse that are helping you to understand pain understand how to live with it and and to kind of manage your own your own symptoms so in that period I had all those things going on at once now that's a lot it was yeah there was a lot to go through there was a lot of things to think about and all and and to just just deal with but it gave me more insight than i would have ever otherwise have gotten so for me even if i was to have done nothing else with the masters for me that would have been
纯属巧合，我也正在通过一个疼痛管理诊所进行治疗。那里的基本配置是：有一名健康心理学家、理疗师、后台的麻醉师，通常还有一名疼痛专科护士，他们帮助你理解疼痛、理解如何与疼痛共处以及如何管理你自己的症状。在那段时间里，我同时在处理所有这些事情。这确实很多，是的，有很多事情需要经历，有很多事情需要思考和应对，但它给予了我前所未有的深刻洞察。所以对我说来，即使我从这个硕士学位中再也得不到其他任何东西，它也是
so fulfilling um that actually it was worth it um anyway for me so i'm gonna now looking at the rest of the masters it's all just a bonus for me which is a fortunate position to be in despite the kind of not so fortunate condition to live with. Yeah and I guess there's something around us being the wounded healers isn't there and actually we learn so much about ourselves and then also how to help others from the stuff that we're being taught and then learning how to apply and work through with others totally and and it's i i think there's a really it's a real place for lived experience in in psychology so and and what i kind of mean by that is that understanding it from a kind of textbook
如此充实，以至于对我而言它本身就是值得的。所以现在展望硕士学位的其余部分，对我来说一切都只是额外的收获。处在这样一个幸运的位置，尽管身上带着这个没那么幸运的病症。是的，我想我们作为“受伤的治疗者”（wounded healers）有这样一种特质：我们从所学的知识中深刻地了解自己，然后也学会如何帮助他人。完全同意。我认为在心理学中，生活经验有着非常重要的地位。我的意思是，从教科书的角度去理解它是
perspective is is is brilliant and obviously it helps hundreds and thousands of people um across the across the kind of uk certainly probably more than that um i should know the stats really but i don't um yeah it there's there's there's kind to help that way but then you've got another level where you can bring your own experiences to things and i think we see this across the board in that when people go from having no children to having children you you have a different mindset about what that experience is so you may have been thinking oh it can't be that bad to to have a very little sleep for eight weeks it can't be that bad to to have a very little sleep for eight weeks it can't be that bad to having to think about father christmas as an example and what that means and what that
极其精彩的，而且显然它帮助了全英国成百上千的人——可能比这还要多，我本该知道这些统计数据的，但我不知道——是的，它以这种方式提供帮助。但随后你还有另一个层面，你可以将自己的亲身经历带入其中。我想我们在各个领域都能看到这一点：当人们从没有孩子过渡到有孩子时，你对这种经历的心态就完全不同了。你以前可能会想：“连续八周睡眠很少，不可能那么糟糕吧？连续八周睡眠很少，不可能那么糟糕吧？不得不考虑圣诞老人是什么意思以及这意味着什么、
does but then you then you come across it and then you start to realize that actually these things are in their own right so little challenges to overcome and then you as soon as you've been through that you have that extra dimension of i, kind of enhanced compassion is I think how I would think about it. And that you have that extra experience to give to other people that can just aid your conversations and understanding of what that person might be going through. With the acknowledgement that actually everybody is individual everybody's experiences are their own and you always have to keep that in your mind but it does give that sense of relatability and that sense of understanding and it kind of gives you a hurdle up which is a slightly ironic thing as a wheelchair user getting a hurdle up because we can't do steps um but it gives you that that that extra
会带来什么，不可能那么糟糕吧？”但随后你真的遇到了，然后你开始意识到，实际上这些事情本身就是需要克服的小挑战。一旦你经历了这些，你就拥有了额外的维度——我认为我会称之为“增强的同理心”。你拥有了可以赋予他人的额外经验，这可以促进你们的对话，并增进你对这个人可能正在经历的事情的理解。同时承认每个人都是独立的个体，每个人的经历都是他们自己的，你必须时刻牢记这一点。但它确实赋予了一种共鸣感和理解感，它给你带来了一个“跨栏”——作为一个轮椅使用者，说“跨栏”有点讽刺，因为我们过不了台阶——但它确实赋予了你
dimension to kind of talk to and ultimately for me to help people um and that that's where um i think i'll bear to add good value to to people's experiences yeah i absolutely agree and i think the longer and longer we're fortunate enough to carry on walking or wheeling around on this earth the more and more we learn and the more hopefully authentic it makes us and our ability to kind of interact and engage with people and I think certainly when I was younger it felt like I was sort of putting on my psychology jacket and you know being able to then use those skills in a certain way with people. But actually, the longer my career has gone on, you know, my professional self and normal self are very much more blurred. And it's, you know, I am just I'm just myself, really.
另一个维度去进行交流，并最终帮助人们。我认为这就是我能够为人们的经历增添良好价值的地方。是的，我完全赞同。而且我认为，只要我们有幸在这个地球上继续行走或转动轮椅足够长的时间，我们就会学到越来越多的东西，这也会让我们以及我们与人互动和交往的能力变得越来越真实。我认为，当然当我年轻的时候，感觉就像是穿上了我的心理学夹克，然后能够在某种程度上对人们使用这些技能。但实际上，随着职业生涯的推进，我的专业自我和日常生活中的自我已经越来越模糊了。而且，你知道，我真的就只是我自己。
And I'm the main intervention. But sometimes I'll use something kind of theory based. And it's not all about me. It's definitely not. But, you know, it's always for me. I'm a person first and a psychologist second. Yeah. Yeah. Gavin, thank you so much for your time in helping us understand a bit more about the process of distance learning and masters and why we might want to do that. Before we finish, could you tell us a little bit about your advice for not burning out as an aspiring psychologist? So I've been asked this question before and I often ponder over it. I think ultimately it comes down to making sure that you have a degree of organization but also ultimately
我是主要的干预手段。但有时我会运用一些基于理论的东西。这并不全关于我，绝对不是。但对我来说，我永远是个人，其次才是心理学家。是的，是的。加文，非常感谢你抽出时间帮助我们更多地了解远程学习和硕士学位办理的过程，以及我们为什么要这么做。在结束之前，你能跟我们分享一下关于作为一名有志心理学家如何防止职业倦怠的建议吗？以前也有人问过我这个问题，我经常琢磨它。我认为归根结底，这在于确保你具备一定程度的组织能力，但更重要的是
being kind to yourself so when you're feeling like you're overwhelmed like there's too much to do that everything is just not where it needs to be and all these things that we all do experience going through any form of learning and frankly within our own careers and and and just our general lives it's just going to take a take a step stop and just take a breath and understand where you are um what you're doing is already fantastic you're already taking on um some wonderful um opportunities to learn and to grow and that actually that in itself is an incredible thing um to be able to say that that you are that you are doing and ultimately you are achieving it so yeah be be kind to yourself um and give yourself that that kind of moment or even a day
要善待自己。所以当觉得不堪重负、有做不完的事、所有事情都不在应有的位置上时——我们经历任何形式的学习，坦率地说在自己的职业生涯和普通生活中都会经历这些——只要停下来，做个深呼吸，认清自己所处的位置。你正在做的事情已经很棒了，你已经在承担一些绝佳的学习和成长机会，实际上，单凭这一点就是一件令人难以置信的事情，你可以说你正在做并且最终做到了。所以，是的，善待自己，
two days three days just take a breath, take a break and kind of get back to it in a refreshed and kind of more considered and mindful way. So Gavin, you are a podcaster. Do you want to tell us a little bit briefly before we finish about your podcast? Yeah, definitely. So the main one is the Safe Place podcast. That's been around for a couple of years now in, in kind of strictly podcast form. So I'm quite traditional on that one in that it is purely a listening podcast.
给自己留出那种时刻，哪怕是一天、两天、三天，喘口气，休息一下，然后以一种焕然一新、更有深思熟虑和更具正念的方式重回正轨。那么，加文，你是一位播客主。在结束之前，你想简单给我们介绍一下你的播客吗？当然可以。主要的那个是“安全港播客”（Safe Place podcast）。它以纯音频播客的形式已经存在几年了。所以我在那个播客上相当传统，它纯粹是一个听觉播客。
I think there was one episode where I might've done it on, on video and they got scared of looking at myself. But yeah, it's, it's out there on, on Apple podcast. It was even in the top mental health podcast for, for a run just before Christmas last year, which was really quite cool. And it's a person that's just had lived experience of living with anxiety or depression or other mental illness. We've got people with BPD on there. We've got people that have been through experiences of living with cancer. We've got
我想有一集我可能用视频录制过，但我看着自己觉得很吓人。但是的，它在 Apple 播客上发布。就在去年圣诞节前夕，它一度冲进最佳心理健康播客的前列，这真的很酷。那是一个拥有与焦虑、抑郁或其他精神疾病共处的生活经验的人的节目。我们在上面采访过患有边缘型人格障碍（BPD）的人，采访过经历过癌症的人，我们在上面还有
people on there who are psychologists in their own right um and and are kind of there to to help share some of their experiences and give a give us another way of looking at at these things um it's a really interesting show it's done live um and it's it's done in a way that we hope is inviting to you to to kind of come in and and feel the the warmth of the show and hopefully learn something new too. And then the second one is one called Disabling Me, which is a brand new podcast. I'm a co-host on it. And the whole idea around that one, it's a social commentary show on living with disabilities. We're going to have guest hosts on there. So we're all having the kind of traditional guest it's everybody coming on to have a conversation about different topics different experiences and just having a kind of warm friendly environment of those conversations that
本身就是心理学家的嘉宾，他们来这里分享一些经验，为我们提供看待这些事情的另一种方式。这是一个非常有趣的节目，是现场录制的，其制作方式我们希望对你很有吸引力，让你能够走进来感受节目的温暖，并希望也能学到新的东西。第二个播客叫“致残的我”（Disabling Me），这是一个全新的播客。我是联合主持人。围绕它的整个理念是，这是一个关于残疾人生活的社会评论节目。我们会在上面邀请客座主持人。所以我们不只是采用传统的嘉宾模式，而是让每个人都来参与讨论不同的主题、不同的经历，并在一个温暖友好的环境中进行这些对话，
we just don't hear as often as as we would we would like to so we thought why not let's let's do our own version of it and let's get those stories out there. Brilliant. It sounds like such important work that you're doing. And of course, when I say work, we don't get paid for this. You know, we do.
而这种对话是我们平时听不到那么多的。所以我们想，为什么不呢？让我们做我们自己的版本，把这些故事讲出来。太棒了。听起来你在做如此重要的事情。当然，当我说是“工作”时，我们并没有为此获得报酬。你知道，我们做的事……
It's a lot of work. You know, when we first connected, we were like, these podcasts are hungry beasts, but it feels like really important work to be doing. I will make sure that I'll link to both of your podcasts in our show notes and in the emails that go out. If anyone wants to join my mailing list, please come on over to goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk. Scroll to the bottom of that first page or any page and I think you can join my mailing list from there. Gavin, thank you so much for your time. Where's the best place for people to find you on socials so you've got two main options you've got linkedin which is i am gavin clark and that's clark with an
这有很多工作要做。你知道，当我们刚开始联系时，我们都在想，这些播客就像是饥饿的巨兽，但感觉这是一项非常重要的工作。我会确保在我们的节目简介以及发送出去的电子邮件中附上你两个播客的链接。如果有人想加入我的邮件列表，请访问 goodthinkingpsychology.co.uk。滚动到首页或任何页面的底部，我想你就可以从那里加入我的邮件列表。加文，非常感谢你抽出时间。大家在社交媒体上找到你的最佳途径是什么？所以你有两个主要选择：你有领英（LinkedIn），我是加文·克拉克（Gavin Clark），克拉克的拼写是 Clark 加上一个
e um and you can find me on there i've got a beautiful photo of me on my wedding day uh with a kind of pink background and a three-piece suit with a lovely blue dickie bow so look out for that and be mesmerized by how cheesy my grin was on that day. You can also find me on LinkedIn, where I tend to share slightly more kind of professional stuff, I guess, but always with the mindset of our lived experiences and some of the kind of things that are going on at the moment in the in the wider world so if you want to kind of hear about some some thoughts on those and some of the
e，你可以在上面找到我。我在上面有一张我婚礼当天的漂亮照片，背景是粉红色的，穿着三件套西装，系着可爱的蓝色领结，所以留意那个，并为我那天灿烂的笑容着迷吧。你也可以在领英上找到我，我倾向于在上面分享稍微偏向专业的内容，我想是的，但始终怀揣着我们的生活经验以及当今更广阔世界中正在发生的一些事情的心态。所以如果你想听到一些关于这些的思考以及我们可以做的事情，这也是一个关注我并进行互动的绝佳地方，来聊聊天吧，我喜欢聊天。非常感谢你接受我两集播客的采访，这绝对是一种荣幸，我受益匪浅，而且非常享受这两集节目。谢谢你，谢谢，这真的是莫大的荣幸，谢谢，谢谢。与加文交谈真是太棒了。我们接下来还有一集关于加文的节目，我们将探讨他的身体健康问题以及他是轮椅使用者这一事实。如果你喜欢这个听觉体验，请留意接下来几周内推出的那一集节目。现在，希望你觉得关于硕士学习的话题
things that we can do that's also a really good place to to follow me and to engage come and have a conversation I like to chat. Thank you so much for speaking to me for two episodes of the podcast it's been an absolute pleasure and i've been illuminated and enjoyed both thoroughly thank you thank you it's been really real real pleasure thank you thank you how wonderful to speak to gavin we do have another episode coming up with gavin where we explore issues around his physical health and the fact that he is a wheelchair user. So if you like the sound of that, then please do listen out for that episode, which will be coming to you in the next couple of weeks. Now, I hope you found the topic about master's study
很有用。我很想知道你对此有何看法。快来“有志心理学家社区”（aspiring psychologist community）告诉我吧。当然，请点赞这集节目，并在 Spotify 和 Apple 上给予评分和评论。如果你在 YouTube 上观看，你知道的，给视频点赞并订阅频道。那就太棒了。所以，是的，我很想知道目前什么对你最重要，请告诉我，快来关注我的社交媒体渠道吧。如果你访问我的 Linktree，那是 Dr Marianne Trent 的 Linktree，你将能够在我的社交媒体中找到它的链接；或者如果你在 YouTube 上观看，你现在会在屏幕上看到一个二维码，你可以扫描它，然后就能访问我的 Linktree，在那里你可以了解关于《临床心理学家合集》（Clinical Psychologist Collective book）、《有志
useful. I'd love to know what you think about that. Do come and tell me in the aspiring psychologist community. Of course, like this episode, rate and review it on Spotify and on Apple. If you're watching on YouTube, you know, like the video and subscribe to the channel. That would be brilliant. So yeah, I would love to know what's important to you at the moment please do let me know come and follow me on my social channels if you go to my link tree there's Dr Marianne Trent and it's a link tree you'll be able to find a link to that in my socials or if you're watching on YouTube you will see a QR code on screen now and you can scan that and then you'll be able to get to to my link tree where you can learn all about the clinical psychologist collective book the aspiring
心理学家合集》（Aspiring Psychologist Collective book）、《棘手大脑工具包》（The Tricky Brain Kit）、《有志心理学家会员计划》（Aspiring Psychologist Membership）以及更多内容。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我期待在我们的下一集节目中与你交流，该节目将于周一早上6点发布。保重。欢迎收听由本播客为您带来的指南，助你走上获得专业资格的道路，这就是“有志心理学家”。我叫亚娜（Yana），是一名心理健康实习从业人员。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书，发现其中所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。通往这一职业的途径竟然有这么多，这让我大为惊叹，
psychologist collective book the tricky brain kit and the aspiring psychologist membership and so much more too thank you so much for being part of my world. I will look forward to catching up with you for our next episode, which will be available to you from 6am on Monday. Take care. guide with this podcast that you'll find to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are
而且成为这一职业并没有完美的唯一方式。这给了我极大的信心，让我确信我并没有做错，并减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书来让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你开始阅读，你就不会放下这本书。本集节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可留下评论。
to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
去达成这个目标，而且没有完美的方法能成为临床心理学家，这给了我信心，让我知道我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你看这个，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读这本书，你就不会把它放下。这个节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。